all right guys we have done it that was
extremely difficult took a ton of time
let's take a look here it is we finally
have the new m2 macbook air we are super
excited to check this thing out in this
video we are going to be doing a
teardown opening this thing up seeing
how the design is what apple has changed
we're going to peel back some stickers
look at the cooler in here uh and check
out the ssds whether it's a single nand
which we're pretty sure it is going to
be
and dang first impressions in my hand
vadim i think you were absolutely right
it is
thin it is light and look at that
beautiful midnight color now every
talking about fingerprints
let's see oh there's my first
fingerprint right there and i just
cleaned my hands before this video
okay
i like this thing
the color is beautiful i'm not a fan of
blue but this blue
is a really nice one it is really dark
it is light i don't know if i should
open it yet maybe it will wait a little
bit it is way thinner than in you know
the photos you can't really tell there
this is a beautiful device this is a
2022 device now let's set this down and
let's grab the cable beautiful braided
cable you do not get this with a more
expensive macbook pro
we have it color matched we have magsafe
on here and then that plug is white
because that's where it connects with
the adapter now we have the base model
so this is the cheaper one that doesn't
come with the dual charger or the fast
charger but that's fine you can buy an
anchor one that's also small and fast
charger we'll leave a link down below
let's grab our ifixit kit i absolutely
love this as all the tools we need uh
it's not too expensive i'll link it down
below as well to amazon let's flip this
bad boy over wow there's actually only
four screws on this thing this might be
the easiest macbook to take apart ever
and as i unscrew this thing i have to
let you guys know about our giveaway we
are giving away a brand new m2 macbook
air we ordered four of them so i'm gonna
send one of these to one of you guys and
it doesn't matter where you are in the
world i don't care if you're in europe i
will pay the import duties the shipping
costs if you guys want to win one of
these we are going to be putting out
videos during this launch week and then
on the 25th of july we will be choosing
a winner randomly on a video
and all you have to do is be subscribed
and comment down below
you can comment on each video to get
more chances but multiples won't help
you so watch our videos comment and one
of you guys are going to get a brand new
macbook now let's see if it just lifts
up or if they have those locks there
all right so the back is not lifting up
so it does have those little locking
channels
oh all right moment of truth let's see
this beauty
okay that is clean that's one thing we
love about apple
especially on the newer products the
insides are just as nice looking as the
outsides let me go ahead and spin this
around so i'm looking at it with the
right orientation
and there are a lot of very interesting
things here the first thing i notice is
the speakers we have these two large
drivers up top these are the whole
modules and if i press down well they
don't press at all that means it's not
bottom firing uh it is actually firing
through the vents over here so it's
going to bounce up through um the kind
of the vents against the screen and
towards your face and also through the
keyboard now we have the dual woofers
that are large we also have the tweeters
and the speakers should sound much
better than before we will do a full
test in our comparison to the m1 macbook
air and right next to it we have these
gold or brass sections now these should
be the antennas i see the little cables
running to there and then we have this
kind of sticker that covers it but
certain sections are cut out that's to
make sure you get the best signal in the
center here we have a protector for the
ribbon cable and we can actually see the
ribbon cable right over here at the
bottom i'm sure apple redesigned it to
get rid of any of the issues they had
before with that disconnecting all right
guys i am even more excited about this
machine now looking at these ports this
reminds me of the mac studio when we did
those tear downs we have screws with all
these covers in each one of these ports
it is a separate piece that can be
unscrewed easily replaced and has a
ribbon cable that connects to the
motherboard so as far as repair ability
it'll be much easier and much cheaper to
do that and the same thing goes with the
headphone jack it's a separate module
here with that it looks like the
trackpad can also be unscrewed and
replaced without having to do it with
the keyboard which was expensive before
and then the batteries have these pull
tabs where you can kind of lift them up
and then yank them to be able to release
these batteries so they're very easily
accessible i'm not going to go ahead and
pull the whole thing up here but we have
all that room and the batteries
themselves they don't need to be tapered
anymore and stacked with different
shapes because of this redesign that is
more boxy that gives us a lot more
internal volume so the batteries are
larger plus they're cheaper and easier
to manufacture just this regular shape
and these insides are very long so
apple's making the most use of the
internal space now with that on the side
here we have cnc low sections with what
looks like magnets on both sides and
then on the front and i'm guessing that
is to hold the lid provide some tension
and then once you
open it up then you can easily release
and open it with one hand which is
really nice with macbooks and this whole
section here at the top is the actual
computer it is so slim it looks like it
has this kind of a metal cover on it and
then this sticker over the top i don't
know how much that draws heat we will be
doing a thermal test video and then
probably see if we can add one of those
thermal pads that we did before that
really helped the m1 macbook air so make
sure you're subscribed but what
interests me the most is this little
door this little hatch right here that
has a screw that allows you to access
something underneath it so let's go
ahead and open this thing up and see
what's inside that was a tiny screw
there
i saw this kind of lift up
let's go ahead and see if we can get
underneath here oh it actually shifted
here that's not good
let's pull this back
looks like i actually might need to
slide out the other way maybe it's an
upgradeable ssd no i'm just joking
absolutely not but let's see what it is
all right it's coming off
and
what is that i don't know what that is
is it a ribbon cable it does look like
some sort of cable and it's folded there
so maybe you need to access that to be
able to unplug something
i'm not really sure but i definitely
don't want to mess it up so it looks
like if we want to see the ssds or the
ssd we have to take this thing apart
further i don't know what do you think
should we keep going
should we stop here
we haven't even turned this thing off
this is max tech
yes this is max tech we did take apart
two max studios all the way and put them
back together and both of them worked so
let's go ahead and first off peel this
sticker all right here we go i got under
the edge there we could start peeling
and we have seen these kind of stickers
before i'm pretty sure it's this
material like not just to help cool it
uh because we have this metal casing we
can see right away so the heat's
transferring from the chip to this metal
casing but just probably to make sure it
doesn't melt because uh this spot is
gonna get really hot without a fan all
right look at that it is actually
changing we do have a thermal pad of
sorts now i'm not gonna touch that pad
itself i don't wanna mess up any of um
whatever coating is there i'm gonna do
this very carefully so we don't damage
it and we can still attach it afterwards
all right and it looks like we have some
chips over here probably some power
chips and the pad actually has another
sticker on there similar to what they
use to cover this that is stuck on so
they just put this pad over everything
all right we have some more chips
underneath here and it's interesting how
this metal top cover has that cut out so
i'm guessing that they don't want the
heat from the m2 chip to transfer to the
top of those chips so it looks like
we're not going to be able to see the m2
chip because this metal cover is
covering the whole thing so i'm going to
go ahead and place this back down
carefully and we'll have to remove that
whole top plate so that's sealed up well
and it looks like on this side as well
it's just completely covered other than
probably another power chip over here
with this case so let's go ahead and
remove it thankfully it looks like we
don't have to remove the ports to get
the motherboard out like on the mac
studio there's plenty of space alright
that was a lot of tiny screws and ribbon
cables with covers and now we can
actually unscrew the whole motherboard
and the plate here we have some smaller
screws here in the center and then some
larger ones on the outsides it looks
like some of these screws are holding
the cover for example these ones here in
the back now it's literally lifting up
while other ones are holding the
motherboard down to the chassis so i
don't want to take the motherboard all
right so it looks like this is a dual
layer cover two separate parts of metal
some of which just grips onto the side
here so we lifted up this whole section
here but then it doesn't really want to
give and we don't want to risk damaging
any thermal things uh if any heat
spreaders anything like that so i went
ahead and i unscrewed uh more of the
screws and it looks like the motherboard
is actually only this section right here
underneath there there's i don't know if
it's either
just a straight pad with some cables
but the motherboard is tiny in this
thing all right we got the display cable
disconnected from the motherboard it's
crazy there's some tiny screws on here
the apple's never used before that none
of the ifixit uh can't get small enough
it's just apple does not want you to
touch that and damage it and now let's
get this out of the way
and bam
here is our
whole motherboard assembly now here you
guys can see good thing we didn't bend
it it might either be
a stamped piece of metal it could have
some kind of a vapor chamber thing in
there
but uh it is super thin now the bottom
of this has nothing
at all it's just completely covered all
right guys we have done it that was
extremely difficult took a ton of time
let's take a look
okie dokie
all right so this is the whole computer
that is an insane amount of chips
everywhere obviously they condensed it
from a macbook pro that has a much
larger motherboard stuff spread out to
everything being
right here in one chunk now
what do we see taking a closer look at
this motherboard we have this apple chip
right here that looks really cool
let us know if you know what that is now
right above that we have this chip that
looks kind of like a nan chip but it is
not one of those we actually looked it
up and it is an ultra wide band chip
this might be the first macbook that has
one of these and i don't even know if
apple mentioned this machine having one
so it might be unlocked in the future
for different things like air tags and
we made a video on airpods pro 2 that
apple could use ultra wideband to get
lossless wireless audio that is super
cool and then here on the left hand side
unfortunately you guys see that empty
slot right there this is the base 256
gig model so we do only have one man
chip apple could have spent a little bit
more money put a second one in and uh
made it just as good as the m1 was but
they didn't of course if you get 512 it
will have two
and right here in the center we have
apple's m2 chip
with the ram right here on the side now
we do have thermal paste here and then
if we take a look at
uh this whole casing that was a huge
pain to remove i would not recommend it
we didn't damage it or anything we were
extremely careful
but we have thermal paste right here as
well so this is a vapor chamber heat
transfer cooling system that attaches
you have different pads here now it's
super thin and based on what we've seen
online as far as thermal testing uh and
thermal imaging it doesn't do much
because the hot spot is still by far
here and
the results that we've seen don't look
too promising now of course we are going
to do our own in-depth thermal testing
not only running cinebench we're going
to look at the frequencies we're going
to look at how much those frequencies
slow down and how long it takes and what
if you do graphics and cpu tests like
you do a lot of times with 3d rendering
gaming video editing photo editing those
tasks how much will it slow down not
just one benchmark so thankfully all of
this is still intact now what i am going
to be doing is i'm going to take off
this thermal paste and i'm going to
reapply another thermal paste that is
very similar to apples we've done
thermal testing in the past with
different pastes
we know the arctic silver is very close
as far as the temps are going to make
sure it's a great seal that everything
is working properly get this thing back
together and then we can continue our
videos and testing so there you guys go
we now officially have visual proof that
this does also have a single nand chip
meaning it's going to read and write at
about 1400 so slower than a 600 m1 ipad
air and you do want to upgrade to 512.
we see all our chips including the m2 it
does have some better thermal
engineering way better
hardware engineering everything is
easily replaceable and accessible other
than this top cover so apple did do a
really good job
so make sure you guys click that
subscribe button above to see the
thermal test and then we're going to do
comparison to the m1 macbook air and
other machines let us know your thoughts
down below this has been max and we will
see you in the next video
[Music]